hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another video about that
rough David I was telling you about um
see as you all may know none I may not
know my computer's not run on a gerbil
in a gerbil wheel in my computer in it
dual scramjet and you know it's um it
was an i7 920 that I bought about two
and a half years ago and it finally
started to die well it's been dying for
a while I've been getting blue screens
of death on startup which is never a
good sign and so I've been just waiting
for the moment for it to die and finally
just kick the bucket yesterday I tried
to get it to start and it wouldn't even
get past the it wouldn't get get it
wouldn't get past daus so that that was
a bad thing so I need to get a new
motherboard I needed to get a new CPU I
needed to get a new RAM just in case and
so I was so excited because I love
buying new electronics and I knew this
day was coming so I went down the store
they're all the Black Friday deals and
I'm behind a new CPU on i7 3770k I got a
liquid cooler for that I've never done
liquid cooling before so I was really
excited to do that
and I got a new motherboard and I got 32
gigabytes of RAM for video encoding some
of you're like oh my no you need you
need a lot for video encoding and
rendering and so I brought it home and I
was outside like World War I get to do
something I knew I was smart because I
backed up all my data and just in case I
bought a copy of Windows 8 which said on
it that you can upgrade and keep your
files so I was so excited to get work
and I put all the components together
one of my favorite things to do on his
building computers and I was working on
it I was working as best I could and it
was going great and then I fired on my
computer and um windows continued to
hard fault even in the new motherboard
which I thought might have been the
problem I thought it I thought it was
just a motherboard that was it but
apparently Windows does not like it when
you change the entire brain if your
computer on it without telling it so it
was giving me hard faults I wrestled
with it for hours trying to do something
because I knew that if I couldn't do it
then I would lose all my data because I
had back things up
I didn't backup everything I backed up
only select few things and I didn't have
my original Windows 7 disks to do a
recovery now I know there there are
people more tech-savvy than me out there
so I was trying everything that I could
save my data and it eventually came down
to it then I was just trying to do the
windows 8 upgrade to try to save my
files but for some reason when Jose did
not like the idea of me doing that so
Windows 8 decided that the partitions
that were already established on my
drives weren't good enough for it no no
I wasn't good enough it needed to
reformat everything not just one I have
two drives ones my backup Drive and it
decided that it wanted to reformat
everything so I couldn't repair windows
because I didn't have my Windows 7 and I
couldn't keep my files because Windows
they wanted to reformat anything so I
wrestled with that forever I ended up
taking my hard drive out putting my hard
drive into another computer and backing
that data up on that hard drive to
another hard drive which I can only do
with one of the hard drives and then I
managed to keep my videos I I still have
a backup of all my videos I've ever done
on YouTube every single one which is
great cuz that's great
so I managed to keep that but I lost
I've lost everything
I lost my thumbnails I lost my fan art I
lost every game that I had that I was
gonna play I lost all my saved games I
lost my save game for Dishonored unless
Steam kept it which it might have I left
I lost my condemned crinimal origins
that was gonna play a loss
Skyrim saves I lost all of my amnesia
custom stories I lost I lost all so
it was a bad day yesterday I was not
happy with that where I am right now as
I was managed to reinstall minecraft I
did the forget-me-nots Annie because I
knew I was going to do that and I knew
where to find it on
and I have on my Adobe production suite
which is good because I couldn't find my
serial number but they were nice enough
to send me the serial numbers so I have
all of that and I have my webcam yay-hey
god it was a long day yesterday I got
home about two o'clock with all the
computer parts and I didn't get
everything to workable state until
twelve twenty at night so I've been
working ten hours straight trying to
wrestle with this trying to save my data
and in the end it was fruitless and I
couldn't save it anyway so anyway I've
been talking away too much about that
you can all understand how that can be
very frustrating here was what I will
say Windows 8 much better operating
system than I had imagined I mean
obviously it's designed for touch but
frankly I haven't been able to tell any
difference between this and Windows 7
terms of the desktop besides to start
menu being gone but then again it took
me five minutes to find a Start menu
online so it's not really that big of a
deal and in the end I kind of I kind of
deleted it because I thought that the
Start menu was kind of getting in my way
as opposed to just hitting the windows
button going straight to Metro or
whatever it's called and um it's a lot
faster it boots up much quicker um
it basically runs better than Windows 7
did and yeah I got no problems with it
if people hate Windows 8 it's because
it's they're not used to the change but
in all honesty I haven't noticed any
slowdown from what I've got once I
configured it in my own way then it was
just fine but that's all I'll say about
that this isn't software isn't be
logging about crap that you don't care
about free kick so let's answer them
questions while I'm here how about that
yeah okay hey mark I have a question for
you how do you get so awesome because
people see me as a loser and a geek but
I think you can give some good advice so
can you please respond dragon spider
flash okay here's a surprise that you
might not imagine and um back in high
school I was not the cool
this guy in town I know I know it's hard
to believe no seriously I was I was in
extreme what I would call loser and
anti-social type I was not in any way
popular I was not the cool guy I mean I
had friends but even those friends up
well you know I wasn't sure how I had
friends because basically I played World
of Warcraft every day and I was a giant
video game nerd and I didn't do anything
I was very in my basement literally my
computer was in my basement so I don't
know when the time change but it really
changed in college because um even in
the beginning college I didn't think
that I was that you know interesting for
first few years and it's it's something
where you get to the point where you
stop caring what other people think and
it's not like it's not you're angry
that's not an angry thing it's just you
stop caring about trying to impress
people and once you do that then you can
actually focus on finding yourself see
once you stop worrying about what what
you look like to everybody else you can
start worrying about what you look like
to yourself and you can when you look at
yourself in the mirror you will see
something that you want to improve or
you see something you're happy with so
um don't worry about the things that you
can't change
like people are out there and
they're always going to be the
people that label you as a loser in the
geek you don't want them as your friends
anyway you'd be surprised how many
people I have impressed and people who
used to not think of me as anything in
high school have suddenly come out of
the woodwork now they found out that I
have a successful YouTube channel you'd
be very surprised like people that I
never even talked to lay hey buddy how'd
it go good now just impress them with
what you have on your own then that's
more than anything they could ever do to
you yeah you're fine on your own you
just need to find it you just need to
take time to work on yourself and that's
all I'll say about that so why do I
always use the name Billy for guys I
don't like in a video game
Tiffany McCullogh I don't know Billy
seems like an easy go to lie I mean it's
a silly name anybody named Billy out
there loser
okay No
no that's there was the opposite in the
okay and so I'm I don't know it's just
kind of my go-to thing I started doing
it in the penumbra playthrough and it's
just kind of stuck ever since so that's
all that what type of game do I play
because I got one for you to play well
like I said I played World of Warcraft
for a long time and that game kind of
stuck with me I was a hardcore Raider
just two years ago on the during Wrath
of the Lich King I I was really into it
wrecks are yeah us wrecks are that was
the server I was on your thousand-yard
so if anybody out there knows plays on
wrecks are and the hosts about yard back
then not as good as farm status on horde
side but we were okay that was my guild
um so I don't really know what other
type of game I play I don't really play
games to relax anymore
I've been trying I've been trying to
find one again you know I've been
dabbling here and there I've been
thinking about getting back into World
of Warcraft again but I just don't have
the time you know it's all a big time
investment something uh thank you pal
man's a 2011 Mia the llama herder asked
have I ever been in love yes if you have
been in love did she know that you liked
her yeah we were dating if she didn't
know did you want her to know that you
liked her okay that's different than
love obviously if you like a girl just
tell her I mean what's the worst that
can happen she says oh no I don't feel
the same way well then there's always
that chance that she'll say yes so you
got at some point you got to work up the
courage because the only thing stopping
you from being any sort of successful
even if it's in terms of relationships
is yourself so if you're your own worst
enemy are you going about the wrong way
cuz you need to be your own biggest
supporter you need look like get some
self affirmation look at yourself in the
mirror like you are good person you are
handsome you are is no loser you know
don't do that that's just cliche and
stupid but seriously you got to believe
in yourself at least a little bit right
do I have partly Asian blood and
an ad na yeah I'm half asian and half
German if you uh if you slit this wrist
rice starts shooting out if you slit
this wrist sauerkraut starts shooting
out like them okay that was oh alright
gt1 reach asks markiplier you got an
interesting voice do something with it
[Music]
I'm a big bowl of mud oh that's good now
three four five six in the asks mark how
many words can I type I've where I've
typed many words in my life can you show
us a picture of yourself when you were a
child I don't have one on hand I don't
even think I have one in this house but
I'll work on that the hack white again
we are the pliers no God no God you guys
aren't that good with making up names
but oh I'm not calling my fans applies
meaning at comic-con everybody bleep
liar liar here oh it's an inside joke
we're all funny right no no don't do
that
you didn't Barris me I wouldn't I would
not I'm not I would not go up and say hi
to you if we he would game up to
comic-con with pliers okay Briar's three
three three oh that was the hack white
that I said rise three through he asks I
know I asked this question before but
it's important on when do you think
he'll be able to get a PA box or
something other sorts I'm working on it
[Music]
okay radical pianist one asks where did
you first meet Bob back in college
yes um Bob and I were freshman year
roommates I think we actually answered
this on a live stream one time but I'll
just tell you it again because it was
probably no not everyone saw it Bob Bob
and I were fracturing your roommates he
was actually supposed to get a guy as
his roommate name my name is Mark
Fischbach and he was told that his
roommate was going to be mark like Frank
Olson or something Leo's name same deal
yep but when Mark Frank Olson Franklin's
not even really Frank Olson when Mark
Frank Olson called him up
it was really awkward because he was
this extremely flamboyant gay guy and I
don't have anything wrong with gay guys
and neither does he but he was you know
preparing that he was gonna have a gay
roommate and all sudden he gets another
call from who he thinks his mark Frankel
Minh Franklin did I say fringle Minh I
don't even remember his name was Mark
Frankel son and he thought this was is
the same guy and I call up with my boys
and I go hey buddy I was going I got an
Xbox gonna bring home Morrow and he was
like so utterly confused because it was
like he went mark I thought like I
changed completely
so because the guy called him up
forehead you know a higher pitched voice
and didn't talk like I knew so I was
interesting and then we we didn't become
really good friends until a few weeks in
when some relationship stuff happened on
both of our ends and we just started
talking like really talking and then we
we've discovered our share interest of
Brian Regan and it just took off from
there so Brian Regan flavored
Thank You radical penis one knee no
Latimer asks class clown no no like I
said um I'm back in high school I was I
was the quietest guy I went through all
of English without reading a single
excerpt and when I did read people were
like what's with that voice because I
you know I always had this kind of
always but I never really acknowledged
it and and then I was sour reason like
the yeah it was the best of times it was
the worst of times and people like hey
we didn't even know you could talk so
yeah I was not the class clown as a
gamer wolf fast when you are at ghoul do
you get noticed and recognized for
videos by people at your college no that
has not happened yet I have not been
unrecognized on the street I don't think
that'll happen anytime soon it's
probably easier for youtubers in other
countries like England or something but
if you think of America and think of the
fact that I have 30,000 over 30 tons of
this make 30,000 make it even 30,000
subscribers maybe half of those watch on
a regular basis that leaves divided
among the 50 states about 3,000 per
state
and if you divided that way a bunch Ohio
just three member population centers you
get Cleveland Columbus and Cincinnati
that means a thousand per place a
thousand people in Cincinnati
probably less watch my videos on a
regular basis probably even less than
that because you have to account for the
other parts of let's say 500 and
Cincinnati really watch my videos on a
regular basis distributed among
population think of how many people are
actually at UC maybe like five ten mix
max ten now think of how many of those
are on campus the exact same time that I
am now thinking how many people those on
campus maybe one or two on time the
exact same time I am are anywhere near
me so it's um I'm not to the point where
people go oh oh if I wear my shirt maybe
my markiplier shirt and I just start
standing on rooftops shouting look at me
look at me look at me look at me are you
looking at me
look at me Who am I and people who go
like off the roof you idiot and then it
would just fine I'll be good
anyway so that's all the question I'm
gonna ask for now I've been going on for
way too long
like always because I ramble like a son
of a but anyway thank you guys for
bearing with me it's gonna take me a
little bit to get back to the games that
I had so expect some rather unorthodox
ones in the coming times um god is
really frustrating to lose all that and
especially there's all the product
process a progress that I had I also
lost progress on some videos that I had
been working on
I'm really sad about but that's a whole
nother story so um it's gonna take me a
little bit to catch up to where I was
thanks for bearing with me I'm sorry
that this happened I mean it'll probably
mean that I can't um get as many videos
as I'd like this week but hopefully by
this weekend I will be better all better
yeah oh oh I totally forgot one piece of
good news
um I am now partnered on Twitch
yes I'm now partnered not to do it so
that means that I make revenue off of
the ads that you all get annoyed by but
now they actually help me they're still
there but now they help me so anyway
thank you guys for helping me get to
that point it's all because you were
there for the weaker weekends and you
know you were there for me and Wade and
Bob so thank you guys again and honestly
just thank you guys for everything the
growth has been phenomenal
I knew that haunt the real slender game
was going to be big and you guys helped
me get pushed up to a good part in the
search rankings at some point I I think
I searched slender and I was number one
so that was that was pretty crazy so
thank you guys for everything that
you've done I don't usually like to ask
you guys to like favorite and subscribe
but or like I don't ask that a lot but
to know that you guys have my back when
I do need that that is incredible so
thank you again thank you for everything
thank you so much for helping out you
guys have been extraordinarily helpful
in it
I'm just um I'm grateful every day that
I get to do to see all the setbacks
aside it's okay I don't mind working to
get it back because it's worth it it's
worth it to get up every morning and
entertain you guys it's worth it to put
in the effort to get back to the point
where I can keep entertaining you guys
on a regular basis so thank you truly
honestly and from the bottom of my heart
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video